I Was teaching in a medical school
Yeah, and I was teaching the concept about genes and everyone of course heard about genes and they believe that genes control their lives
You know so running in my family is diabetes Alzheimer's cancer, whatever it is, and they say oh my goodness
I'm a recipient of such genes and this is gonna be my life
And this is a belief of victimization of victimization of heredity
It's running in my ready and I gonna get these genes and I can't control it
There's a new biology that switches this whole thing around because it reveals that genes don't control our lives
It's our perceptions and our response to the environment
It's the environment that influenced the genes well the relevance about that is since we can change our perceptions
And we can change our environment, then we're not victims
We're actually masters
But we have to know that we have to really come from an understanding that we are creating our lives because if your belief is
You're a victim its belief is translated into biology you become a victim if that's what you believe yes, sir
So you kind of prove scientifically and biologically that the proof of that that that we in fact are in control of our genes that
Our genes aren't controlling our lives
Can you give us a brief sort of bird's-eye view of how you prove that yeah, it's a wonderful simple experiment about 47 years ago
I was cloning stem cells now about 47 years ago
There's only a handful of us in the whole world even knew what a stem cell is it's a stem cells an embryonic
Cell in your body and the reason why we have all these embryonic cells because cells have a life
And they die and if we can't replace the cells then it won't be very long before all our cells die
And then we're gone so in stem cell is a multi potential embryonic cell
Here's the work simple I get one stem cell put in a dish by itself and it divides every 10 hours
So first one and then two four eight sixteen and the cells keep going after a week
I've got fifty thousand cells in the petri dish, but here's the most important point they all came from one parent
So they're fifty thousand genetically identical cells okay now
Here's the experiment here
I take that community and I break them up into three different petri dishes
And I change the environment a little bit in each dish now cells are like fish
They live in a fluid so I create like an aquarium with all the things they need to live in it
that's called the environment and
I change the composition of the environment a little bit in each dish, okay
What happens is in dish one I get muscle cells in dish two I end up with a different environment get bone cells in dish
Three yet a different environment. I end up with fat cells well the whole point was this
What controls the fate of the cells and you say well genetics?
I go no no they were all genetically the same yes, so the fate of the cell wasn't determined by the genetics
It was determined by the environment
Okay
And so the information in the environment is really what's involved with selecting our genes so people say well
Okay, that's really nice. You got cells in a plastic dish
What the heck does it have to do with me and I go well?
Here's the fun part you look in the mirror tie you look you see this handsome guy looking back you say that's tie
That's me, and I'm a single human being a single organism. I go a slight misperception for this reason
You are not a single entity you are made out of 50 trillion cells the cells are the living entity
You by actual biological definition you're a community
So you're a community of 50 trillion cells and so the fun part is you're a skin covered petri dish
With 50 trillion cells inside and you have an environment a culture medium, and it's called blood and the chemical composition of the blood
Determines the fate of the cells that's what happened in my plastic dish so to a cell
Does it make a difference if it's in the plastic dish or the skin dish no it's still gonna read the environment
So I say ah then the blood is the culture medium and the composition of the blood controls the genetics
And then I go yeah now here's the cool part
I say
But as I showed in the petri dish if I change the composition of the of the culture medium
I change the fate of the cell so I say well
Who or what controls the chemical composition of my blood so we go up to the next level I say the brain is the?
Chemist the brain is what releases the chemistry in the blood and then you go one more step you say
But what chemicals should the brain release into the blood I go next level up the mind
What do you perceive?
What do you see? What are you looking for so I say forgive a person I say?
Here we are I stand here. I open up my eyes, and I see someone I love
Well my mind perceives love and translates that through the brain
Into chemistry such as dopamine the pleasure chemical oxytocin the bonding chemical vasopress and attractiveness growth hormone
Which enhances the growth of the cells so when a person sees love?
Experiences love the brain releases a cocktail of these wonderful chemicals and and think about it when people are in love they glow
They're healthy there you have so much energy
I said what how where they get that from the culture medium okay, but I say look same person
Opens their eyes instead of seeing someone they love they see someone that something that scares them
I say do you release these same chemicals in love and I go no no
When I perceive the world is threatening or I'm living in fear I release stress hormones, and I release
hormones that control my immune system
Inflammatory agents these things that get me ready for flight or flight
And I go well here's the interesting part
As I said the fate of the cells is based on the chemistry if I take the chemicals released by the brain and love and
Put into a plastic dish with cells yeah the cells grow beautifully
And I say okay wait
What about the chemicals that come out of a brain of someone in fear I take those chemicals put that in the culture dish
the cells stop growing and
And they get into protection protections close yourself down so the idea is this when you're in growth
You're open to the world and you say come on bring it on yeah
But when fear or something comes in there you close it down and the chemistry of the fear is what shuts down the cells
Fear kills
Basically what it's all about so basically it says this we always talk about mind body and those strict fundamental scientists go
And I go it's not a mystery it's simple the mind is an interpretation of the world
It causes the brain to release chemistry that matches the interpretation to coordinate
50 trillion cells to live in that world it's your emotions. It's your perceptions
It's your beliefs these are the sources of the chemicals that end up controlling the genes. This is a new science. It's called
Epigenetics because epigenetics is a revolution of all of our understanding of science for a very simple reason when I was a professor in a
Medical school we were teaching the concept of genetics and genetics most everybody knows yes
We have genes and the genes control our traits
And that we get the genes from our parents and and so therefore the traits that are running in our family are passed down to
Us and sometimes it's a good thing and sometimes a bad thing
Everybody my family got cancer it's like am I gonna be next I got the genes yeah
So that's our belief system that we've been teaching that genes control us that makes us victims as I said because
We didn't pick the genes as far as we know we can't change the genes so whatever they are they make us
And so people walk around going oh my life is you know not so good. I got these genes epi means above
So when I say epigenetic control, I'm literally saying control
Above the genes, it's the environment that controls it well that includes not just the real environment
But our perception of the environment because you could live in the healthiest of environments
But if you perceive it to be a threatening world then it's your cells receive the perception. They don't read the direct world
Genetic control you're a victim because the genes control you
Epigenetics is a is a revolution because it says look if the environment of my perception controls genes
I'm the one that can change my perception. I'm the one that can change my environment so all of a sudden
I'm not locked in I am free to change the way
I live in the world which in turn comes back and changes the genetic readout
And this is really what's so profoundly important for example a lot of people talk about the placebo effect yes
And I say well, what's the placebo effect well?
This pill is going to cure you it's the greatest new science in the world
And I believe that and I take the pill and I get better and then they tell me it was just a sugar pill
So then the truth is well what healed me well it wasn't the sugar pill
It was the belief in the pill so everyone says oh, yeah, placebo effect
That's how you have this wonderful thought you get better, and I say yeah, but here's the problem
We've only talked about the placebo effect
There's another thing called the nocebo effect the nocebo effect is what is the consequence of a negative thought and it turns out?
It's equally powerful in controlling your biology and your genetics as is a powerful as a placebo positive thought yeah
So we talk about oh, yeah, placebo good thoughts create good health and good life
And then I say yeah and a bad thought a negative thought a nocebo effect can actually kill you
It can cause a disease if you believe you're gonna get this cancer because everyone says you're gonna get this cancer
And then your perception is sending cancer thoughts into your body the chemistry
That comes from the thoughts to the brain to the body is a chemistry that doesn't support health
But it'll actually lead to your own death so all of a sudden
It's the power of your perceptions positive or negative that override your genetics
Well this is most amazing because all of a sudden you look around you say
But look at all those wonderful happy people look they're not only just happy they're also healthy yes, and the fact is yes
They're sending in a chemistry that the cells will really thrive with in this world
It is true that people want immediate action. That's the world we live in immediate gratification, so if I'm sick
I want something immediately to handle the issue and of course we look to the world of drugs for for this
Understanding but the problem with this is that there are more effective ways of healing now the problem with the
Energy healing is that it really involves?
consciousness mind
And our ability to change our belief systems well this takes a little bit more work than popping a pill and in fact
I just had my own particular case
I remember years ago when I was getting off on this out of my conventional medical academic background and coming into this world
And I face a stressful situation where I got pneumonia, and I started to realize at some point. It's okay
I'm gonna sit here and and
Grab a hold of this with my conscious and my spirit and get my immune system all pumped up and work on this and I
Started to realize that the the bacteria were dividing faster than my ability to control the bacteria
And so it came a realistic moment. It said yes
I know I can possibly control this but the effort that it's going to take it's going to take a little bit more
Time than the drug, so I actually went and bought the penicillin and the significance is when you need it
You need it at that moment, but the issue is had I not been stressed had I taken care of my health a little bit better
I would not have come to that precipice where I was forced into taking the drugs and so the reality is that
In switching from a drug based reality into an energy medicine spirit based reality
We have to go through a learning curve and learn how to take control of our thoughts our mind and
Control the biology that we were given
When we do that then it's far better than the drug world for a very simple reason there are no side effects
And so basically it says that if you start healing with spirit and energy
That you get an unencumbered healing process as compared to dealing with drugs
And then dealing with the myriad side effects that are listed on all the packages, so
It says both work
But one is far superior to the other and yet. I wouldn't throw out the medication because when it's necessary
It's necessary, but it's just a little warning to you when your symptoms start going up
It says pay attention to the symptoms because the symptoms are really informing you that you're not living in
Harmony or in health and that the body is telling you this and so rather than shutting off the symptoms with a drug
It's really important for us to take on a learning role and say I am creating this situation and I can
Uncreate the situation without the use of drugs if you want some amazing
Affirmations with dr. Joe Dispenza check it out right there next to me
I think you'll enjoy it continue to believe and I'll see you there when I'm going through change in my life
Or I will have a specific outcome that I want to create. I love to get up early in the morning. That's my time
I'm a 4 30 in the morning guy because that's my time